the main question for the jury was this
should police have stopped stephen port
after his first murder and so saved his
later victims
the first victim was found outside
port's home fashion student anthony
wallgate a month later the body of
artist gabriel kavari in the churchyard
nearby
three weeks later in the same churchyard
chef daniel whitworth daniel's parents
didn't need to wait for the jury's
conclusion it was clear to anybody that
he should have been stopped
anthony there and
nobody else needed to die there
but unfortunately that wasn't the case
the victims were all young gay men
killed at port's flat
all dead from an overdose of a date rape
drug ghb
all dumped outdoors local police refused
to connect the deaths or treat them as
suspicious
they were each found similarly with
drugs in their pocket
that port planted there and
they weren't going to look outside that
particular box it's you know this is
what gay people do they go to to parties
they go to chem sex parties
i mean crikey daniel didn't have the
time of day
to give
to that kind of lifestyle
it wasn't until the death of a fourth
victim jack taylor a year later
that the murder squad took over
they found footage of jack meeting
stephen port port was arrested and
convicted
it's really important that he tell us
the absolute truth
[Music]
he drugged his victims to have sex with
them
in front of the coroner victims families
heard police admit serious errors
during the inquests individual police
officers blamed understaffing and
overwork for their failures
but a friend of one of the victims said
it was more than police incompetence
what he called institutional homophobia
john pape was a friend of gabriel the
second victim
when the third victim daniel died he
started emailing police with his
suspicions of a crime
he wrote i worry about what is happening
to young men in barking
when he got no response he wrote again
let me be blunt i have had indirect
information a scenario in which older
men drug younger men in order to take
advantage of them sexually
during the hearing the detective he
wrote to admitted ignoring his emails
and failing to warn her colleagues of
possible murder she was also the cavaris
family liaison officer but she failed to
contact them
there were other mistakes
port was arrested and jailed after the
first murder but only for lying that he
didn't know the victim
police didn't examine his laptop for 10
months and missed evidence of his date
rape obsession
detectives fell for a suicide note left
by daniel whitworth in which he
confessed to killing gabriel kavari
stephen port had written it
there were a number of
investigative errors
but the coroner has directed the jury
away from being able to find
that prejudice played a part and i agree
with that i don't think the met is
institutionally homophobic
i do think that the errors that happened
were very grave and i'm very sorry that
they did
for daniel whitworth's parents sorry
wasn't enough i want them gone they're a
public liability how can
how can the safety
of of people who pay taxes
for this
kind of protection that they think
they've gotten they clearly
haven't
why are they there
why are they there why are they there
getting promoted
the police watchdog the iopc found nine
officers had performance failings but
none was disciplined
five have since been promoted
martin brunt sky news barking